okay I've watched you over the years La
girl
I loved your Super Bowl last year
representing West Coast rap it's what I
grew up on I grew up near that
neighborhood it's like my favorite music
in the world I've feel like I've known
you admired you listened to you dance to
you party to you you know for the better
part of my beautiful life much more
beautiful because of you
but I see you in different modes at
different times in your life what is
going on right now and why are you so
damn sexy
because I want to be here you know I I'm
enjoying my life I'm one for once in my
life enjoying my life enjoying Mary and
and and just embracing everything about
me you know accepting the good the bad
the ugly the things I can change the
things I can't change it's just all me
and I'm not gonna get another me so I'm
just embracing it you know and it's a
process every day you know saying
wonderful things about myself to myself
even things I don't believe as long as
it's wonderful you know what I mean
this is such a rich subject for me right
now because I'm I am trying to make a
turning point I'm at a Tipping Point I
believe in my life is that something
that you have to work on and since when
I developed this uh when I got a divorce
um while I was in the marriage and for
years I've been just insecure didn't
like my the sound of my voice didn't
like what I looked like didn't like
anything about myself and then when I
got married the person just really
watered that seed of of my own
self-doubt and my own insecurity and
made it worse yes and um I Heard um tdj
said he said um what you say about
yourself
and how you think about yourself is way
more important and effective than what
anybody else can say or think about you
so if you yes if you speak positively
over yourself and that's what I started
doing so my first my first big
confession was an album I put out called
good morning gorgeous I didn't believe I
was gorgeous ever but I had to say
something I didn't believe you know that
was bigger than me and then it began to
manifest in my heart my heart is
gorgeous my my mind is gorgeous I'm a
beautiful person you know I'm so I
so you have to believe that about
yourself this
means so much to me too because I saw
all this stuff you know when I was a kid
and sort of you know raised myself for
better or worse crashed and burned like
lost my job got institutionalized like
had to emancipate myself when I was 14.
and by the time you're you know and
you're like 14 midlife crisis I guess
that's you know where we're at
numerically off but this is where I met
my life and I I had fooled myself into
thinking that the hardest times I'd ever
go through on my journey in this life
were then it had nothing on divorce it
had now tell me about it yeah I just you
know you see those strong amazing people
and you were like how did they get so
broken
that was me yeah and I had to put myself
back together piece by piece by piece
and then I'm like I'm in my mid-40s now
I'm 48 and I am
tired of this inner voice that is so
toxic well let me just share this with
you it's not going to happen overnight
I'm still it's a process I have to say
it every day I have to I love you Mary I
have to say it every morning I'm you're
a masterpiece you have to find it for
yourself and and that's it you got to
find it for yourself I found it for
myself and that's this is what I believe
it's not for I'm not saying this because
I want the whole world to believe what I
believe this is what was has me looking
sexy like you said the Masterpiece is
what's inside then it's it's it's your
heart and believing that you have
goodness in you and and okay you mess up
you have bad things you have you even
doubt yourself but earlier I said accept
all of you yeah you can accept all of
you then nobody can mess with you
because you know you're this and you
know you're not that you know you guys
following what I'm saying I do and I
know I'm the happiest I've ever been in
my whole life I Know It This birthday 48
I had the best birthday I've ever had in
my whole life I felt whole it's the
first feeling of wholeness I've ever had
in my life you know and it's been
building it's been scaffolding up there
for years and years and years exactly
yeah and you're still here so keep
building
and yeah it's all the more relatable
though when you see an icon such as
yourself that says yeah I struggle
you're like oh God you do too okay
because you're Mary J Blige I mean
you're incredible thank you
[Applause]
oh well let's not let's not shortchange
you your glue you are one of the biggest
TV film stars since you were a child
you've always had something bigger than
a lot of people you know what I'm saying
and you're huge you're Drew Barrymore
look I I love you in E.T you were so
cute
I've loved you since you like came out
as such a strong woman and it speaks to
your children's book that I love so much
and we're gonna do our next segment
about that so I don't want to over speak
about it but
one beautiful
Concept in it is the strength to believe
in yourself
and I wonder you know through
through everything that you've seen and
done what or who
do you think was one of your big
Inspirations to believing that you could
do all these things so many people
um well I have to say my mother was
definitely one of one of those people
and she's in the book like single parent
yep mother uh raised us in the projects
it was hell but she did it and and we
don't we don't know how but she did it
um my grandmother and then um
puffy because he was a huge inspiration
when I came in the game he I didn't like
myself I didn't want success I was
afraid of it but watching him he wanted
it so bad and he was it it was just like
okay I'm gonna learn this hem Jay-Z
um 50 Cent
um Oprah Winfrey Michelle Obama
President Obama it was just so many
people to say you know what
I can do it too you know and they
they've been they've inspired me I mean
that's an amazing list of people it is
so true I
I love Curtis yes I love Curtis so much
he comes and plays on this show all the
time he's been very very kind to me
since I started this show and you're in
power yeah
yes
[Music]
what what is something that comes to
your mind about like acting versus
singing
what things do they satisfy you what
things do they scare you with what what
gives you confidence in what are the
differences between the two for you well
acting is a challenge because it's new
and it's hard it's really really hard
so the difference between acting and
singing and singing is not hard is
I'm Jordan with that I you know that's
nothing
well
you know what
you are
chip book has such a specific point of
view and I'm telling you you will get
this message and get this story but it
is um it is called Mary can but I want
to bring out two uh favorite friends of
ours to do a book review on it
[Music]
foreign